é quando ingressam por montar o papo
reto pra vocês nem situação de tap para
veracruz
hanói ranço você fada que eu tive eu vou
contar para vocês só com a salada mista
sentir o beijo entrei hoje em dia 12 ana
viana pede que acerta as meninas autor
ballack até o absorvente a ré também
dando com a vila eo brincavam de casinha
hoje em dia com 10 anos já não tem
camisa e jogar bola com os muleques na
calçada sem medo quando ea bater a falta
de resultados o pão do dedo assinado não
derruba pra minha roupa não sujar seu
filho da minha roupa minha mãe vai me
matar hoje em dia o moleque nem quer
saber de brincar descobriram a polícia
agora não querem parar a mãe vai lá no
quarto pedido pelo estúdio ele espera
muito me seu pai eterno redtube menina
de 13 anos se enrolando com o meu aqui
estão tentando desde rolar o meu clone
meninas em 12 anos e já se acha grandona
site na rua mostrando os seus pedidos de
azeitona não sei pra que essa idéia de
janeiro é sedutor foi na rua desfilando
fazendo corte de tudo foi toda tava de
boa não parava de playboy só porque
estava na roda e você roda de funk a
bota evans ea roda
a marcha foi [__] a vaga de bola não
parava de playboy só porque estava na
moda e você roda fãs ea roda infância
roda o funk a foto quando eu era criança
a filha quero volta a menina ficava quem
assim não se cala a boca é gol mandou
calar a boca eu não deixava eu deixava
ela pôs a mão na boca cheia no jogo da
velha luta vem a luta já morreu cheiro
quando o seu papel seu cabelo já viajou
o cheiro quando seu avô seu avô já
morreu semana a minha bolsa sou eu pedi
rapariga
eu não deixarei de rapariga que me chama
chapa quente não há como tornar meu beco
leito bebe gama e no meio disso tudo era
não ter inimigos mesmo depois de brigar
continuam amigos essa era a essência
nada era pela roda por isso que eu tenho
orgulho de dizer que a minha infância
foi fatal foi toda estava de boa não
pagava de playboy só porque estava na
moda
ora se a roda infância roda na infância
fora me fazia foi [__] estava de bola
não passava de playboy só porque estava
na moda
rosa se a roda infância [__] infância
[__]
valeu galera você curtir essa música
esteja fazendo e clique em junho a gente
tem alguns cursos para poder fazer as
coisas não consegue chegar num lugar
pelo que ele não pensa numa lógica que
está me ajudando você clicar neste link
você vai para o site da loja estão os
bens mas lá os pés fumaça vender você
clicando aqui eles vão saber que foi por
causa do meu vídeo que você chegou no
site então você clique neste link
e você vai me ajudando mas só me ajudou
aqui é foi a galera do facebook tem a
galera do canal tarde zoeira também
espero que vocês tenham gostado e
desabafar e com isso nesse canal e não é
se inscreve no canal em baixo aí haja no
facebook clique aqui na minha mão para o
canadá o cartão na mão dele é isso aí
valeu para assistir o vídeo até aqui
clique em inscrever-se aí pra continuar
vendo vocês sabem falou epe a louvável